It's not all that happens though,
when they eat the fruit of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil,
because it's not called the fruit of the tree of the knowledge of nakedness.
It's called the fruit of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
And I thought about that for a tremendous amount of time.
It's like what in the world, because I assume these old stories make sense.
You know, it's a game I play. It's like, they're old,
they've been around a long time. I'm not sure why they're there.
There, but there they are. They're at the basis of our culture.
Many, many of the stories that we depend on depend on them,
our whole culture grew out of their roots, let's say.
And so I assume that our ancestors who've managed to survive conditions that
would have done a lot of us in very rapidly.
I can tell you we're a lot smarter than we think,
and that the mysterious processes that,
that produced these stories and compelled us to remember them are a lot more
psychologically significant than we generally tend to presume.
So I give them the benefit of the doubt and try to understand why it is that
they might make sense instead of assuming that they don't and that that's not
easy as they're complicated stories.
And so I thought about this nakedness knowledge of good and evil idea for a
very, very long time, like about 20 years,
puzzling it out was what the hell is the relationship between discovering that
you're naked and discovering good and evil.
And then one day mostly because of studying totalitarianism,
totalitarianism and the atrocity that proclivity for people to commit
atrocity in the service of their group belief,
or maybe just because that's what they were like clued me in.
And I thought,
I see this is one of the things that really makes people different than animals.
It's like, you know,
it's one thing to realize that you're naked to realize that you're naked means
that you know,
that you're limited in time and space that you're mortal and that you're,
you're subject to degeneration and to social humiliation and to your own harsh
judgment,
all of that nakedness to know that you're vulnerable against the
world.
And definitely a source of shame because of that and
felt lack of self-sufficiency and no wonder,
no wonder it's understandable.
But the other thing is is that this is, and this is the rub it's like,
if you're out in the Velt and you're not being very careful and a hungry lion
jumps on you and eats you, you don't really think of the lion as evil. I mean,
you might right at that moment, but you know, philosophically,
it's not evil, it's just hungry. And as soon as it's not hungry,
then it goes and has asleep.
And it's not up to some malevolent trick it's it's done for the day,
but human being that's a whole different sort of creature.
And because human being is capable of doing terrible things to someone else
and consciously, so you think, well,
what's the connection between that and nakedness itself. And it seems to be,
this is like,
here's the thing is that once I realized that I can be hurt, you know,
I have a self-conscious model of my own vulnerability,
then I can generalize that to other people I can think, Oh, this is interesting.
Here's how I can be heard by myself. Here's how I can be hurt by society.
Here's how I can be hurt by nature and by the unknown.
And what that implies is that, well,
you can be hurt with exactly the same mechanisms
and that immediately becomes part of my,
what would you say? My repertoire of ability?
And then all of a sudden the world is no, uh, Wald
walled garden and a well-watered place,
but it's a moral story because with that ability to
inflict suffering comes the knowledge of good and evil.
As far as I'm concerned,
those are identical propositions because now we have the choice,
a deep choice about how we're going to treat ourselves in each other.
We can inflict tremendous pain and suffering on each other in a
very voluntary and,
and conscious manner in, in, in a way that no other animal can manage.
And that's the dawning of the moral sense that
capacity we now have to choose to
mitigate or exaggerate suffering. And that's not all,
but it's a huge part.